so I started cutting hair for homeless
people about a year ago now
[Music]
like something short around the sides
kind of like mesh around the top a bit
the last time I got the haircut was
about six months ago I was looking for a
way to give back on my community and
feel more human really oh yes great
didn't expect someone to come up to me
out of nowhere and offer my haircut
[Music]
it's always better for the hairdresser
to just dive in with white likes okay
that's it yeah this is about so much
more than just a haircut it's about
connecting with people so using your
time is the most important thing lending
your ear to those who might burn visible
and telling their story to break down
the stereotypes I'll feel a lot better I
can feel the wind on the side of my head
which I haven't felt good free bubs
and I can just see the people looking
walking past and smiling so if they must
have done a great job
Wow it's amazing to always trust the
hairdresser
[Music]